el martes por la mañana el cielo de la
capital sudanesa jartum se cubrió de
humo una gran explosión interrumpió
momentáneamente una emisión del Canal
pan árabe Arabia los combates entre
facciones rivales el ejército nacional y
el grupo paramilitar Far se encuentran
ya en su cuarto día decenas de civiles y
combatientes han muerto y resultado
heridos mientras continúan los combates
muchos residentes están atrapados en sus
casas
en los últimos días casi todos hemos
permanecido dentro de casa intentando
mantener la cordura los bombardeos
suelen empezar sobre las 4 de la
madrugada y duró en unas horas pero hoy
no han parado no sé si se oye de fondo
pero esta ha sido la historia de los
últimos cuatro días
el martes por la mañana el secretario de
estado estadounidense Anthony blinken
declaró que un convoy de la emba
estadounidense había sido atacado el
lunes la Unión Europea dijo que su
enviado a Sudán había sido asaltado en
su residencia mientras los
enfrentamientos se recrudecen pesos
pesados internacionales como Estados
Unidos y Egipto han intentado acercar a
las dos partes
estamos dispuestos a mediar con nuestros
hermanos de Sudán para alcanzar una
tregua y celebrar negociaciones esto
sigue en pie nuestro contacto con el
ejército sudenes y las fuerzas de apoyo
rápido continúa
el ejército de Sudán y las autoridades
de las fuerzas de apoyo rápido acordaron
un cese al fuego que entrará en vigor la
noche de este martes y se extenderá por
24 horas para garantizar la seguridad de
los civiles que salgan del país sin
embargo ambos bandos confirmaron que la
armisticio no se extenderá más de un día